le tamarin et le troisième acidifiant le
plus utilisé dans le monde après le
vinaigre et le citron et pourtant il
plutôt méconnu des nord américains
on le trouve frais sous forme de gousses
de patte de pulls de concentrer et même
aux bongo ce smash jeunesse tout ça
qu'on voit sur la table sous ma jeunesse
j'ai grandi à aumont paquin accents les
petits bonbons ici c'est je courais dans
la cour d'école puis je mange se dresse
à mu a eu cependant découvrir le chef
d'origine laotienne à tirage phrase avat
a grandi avec le tamarin ça c'est
vraiment le fruit de l'arbre
ça c'est vraiment le fruit de l'arbre
mais ça c'est le fruit aux halles et un
mur s'ils sont le fruit à de l'arbre
directement la peau des élèves est très
très très bien calme en vert fluo
alors qu'en vol de cartes qui al'intérêt
ivan brun très foncé j'ai extrêmement
sucré alors filez les autres fais
attention très collant aussi s'ouvrir ça
ça super bon j'adore il s'avère d'une
pas tomine date
cécile en fin de compte le mot tamarins
vient de nos d'un mot arabe
tamaryn que des dates hinds et le goût
c'est assimilé au début comme comme si
on conjure est comme si on m'aurait dans
une lime à ce pas la suite
il ya une ou deux dates à la fin puis ça
revient créé pour le chef d'origine
haïtienne paul toussaint chaque goose
renferme une surprise doit trouver
certains qui sont très peu il ya
beaucoup de paepe dedans il y en a qui
sont comme vraiment il ya moins de de
purpan dont il ya d'autres qui sont
vraiment acide y en a qui sont gourmands
sucré ac c'est toujours comme des
valeurs c'est que ce soit en asie ou en
amérique latine le tamarin est à la base
de nombreux plats
c'est vraiment réputé dans l'amérique
latine au complet la sicav à 46 ça on
consomme beaucoup ça on utilise pour
faire des robes ou le poulet des sauces
comme arrachés de taman c'est le produit
par excellence un peu gens qui touchent
aux confins de ketchup ou zabbaline pour
changer nous savons tous ici c'est
vraiment intéressante ici on a travaillé
avec tomates et puis on à travers
oignons ail tient un peu de vinaigre de
cidre pour aller chercher ça un petit si
possible pour ramener un peu plus ce
côté sucré ketchup voix on a cru la
tomate en adresse ip man réduire jusqu'à
faire marc une bonne part et puis on va
balancer ça avait taman
lorsque tu veux chercher un autre court
en couple aux attentes si tout ça ce
qu'on fait comme je fais un jack de base
on va essayer de chercher comme un côté
plus soyeux tout ça et avoir un goût
aussi plus funky
blatter avait ajouté ahmad
tout beau donc même pour nos mairies
n'allons pas utiliser du tamarin oui oui
ce qui est bien votre travail notamment
par ozon d'ajouter parfois dans cette
annonce et a besoin d'un peu de miel aux
médecins ou des capteurs besoin ajouter
un côté sucré
notamment il va faire les deux lacets et
le sud d'avoir accusé la scène politique
souvent pour les salades et papaye
affalé sur base de sauce barbecue aussi
entendez parle comme ça on utilise pour
marier les libyens alors je n'ai pas de
jambes galanga échelle at elle ajouté on
ferait juste avait réchauffé absent mais
nous crever après les crevettes
on a mis notre sauce barbecue pour
tamarins je serai serait dur pendant sa
régie sac à la mise enfin notre salade
de papaye emon pour medal morceaux à
part de tamar et la daille à la limite
des choses ensemble
par la suite on ajoute nos leaders des
haricots tomates du chou la papaye la
mangue et bien sûr le tamarin et voilà
ça de papaye mangue et créerait tout a
mal paru
que c'est beau pour nous réchauffer un
peu paul et son mix la bonne aventure
nous suggère un remède à saveur
tropicale le corossol qoleib à l'instar
de course accolade à on a dû
du jus d'ananas donc on a dû sirop
tamarins donc fait maison
suite je mets une ans et demi de purée
de corps au sol donc instituée maître
baroque ou 4 étoiles donc il va apporter
des notes de vanille et de caramel et
2011 de saint germain de saint germain
qui est une longueur de sureau assez
floral
c'est presque une danse la chanson à
damas ramené à la vie ram et un peu plus
de soleil dans notre lit qui est qui est
un peu plate mais non je pense qu on
peut plutôt un qui m'a dit on va juste
lever nos verres
ses addictions à 6 tout ça c'est mon
premier au ca sera pas le dernier
[Musique]